we have a big show this morning Gayle
King is along the us-mexico border and
we're going to hear from her in just a
moment Alex Wagner is here with us the
battle over the Trump administration
zero tolerance policy on immigration is
intensifying with lawmakers in both
parties condemning it as cruel and
inhumane the administration still
defends the strategy thousands of people
protested across Texas yesterday they
accused the administration of punishing
undocumented children by removing them
from their parents the Department of
Homeland Security confirms 1995 children
were separated from their parents
between April 19 and May 31st Gail is in
McAllen Texas leading our team along the
southern border she has been talking to
parents recently reunited with their
children right now she's at a Border
Patrol facility where hundreds of
migrant families are being detained Gail
a lot of people are deeply distressed
about the story good morning I'm one of
those people deeply distressed I'm so
glad we're here and that we have a team
here to bring a light as to what's
happening we landed yesterday afternoon
Alex we jumped in a car drove an hour
and we went to a location where parents
had just been reunited with their kids
some of them had been separated for as
long as six days and all I can say to
you is this the Statue of Liberty based
on the stories that I heard and the
people that I've talked to and the
things I saw with my own eyes the Statue
of Liberty is really weeping today but
let's start here exactly where we are
behind me this converted warehouse is a
first stop for many of the undocumented
families caught at the southern border
it's where federal officials try to weed
out criminals an executive officer at
the center told us and by the way look
at the center it's a nondescript
unmarked building and that it is built
that way for a reason they don't want
you to know exactly what happens behind
that building the 55,000 square foot
facility can hold about 1500 people
yesterday more than 1,000 were being
processed here that includes more than
500 families 197 unaccompanied children
David Begg know was part of a select
group of reporters who got to see inside
the facility so David what did you see
it was rare that they let you inside
what you see Joe we saw people in cages
agent engages they look like animal
kennels we could not record anything we
couldn't talk to anyone all they allowed
us to do was take notes so here's what
we saw there were cages with fathers and
kids there were other cages with mothers
and kids in one place there was a cage
of just children unaccompanied minors
were told that crossed the border alone
some had blank looks on their faces some
were smiling and walking around we had
15 minutes to document everything these
are the images the government gave us to
show you of the Rio Grande Valley
processing center the facility appears
to be clean and sterile children and
adults are seen huddled together in the
building that's divided up into
chain-link fencing that looks like a
cage Monique Graham is an executive
officer at the center she says parents
without an extensive criminal history
will not be separated from their
children if the child is 4 years old or
younger what happens if you're 5 and
older and your mother or father doesn't
have a significant criminal history the
child will not be prosecuted the adult
will under the Trump administration
zero-tolerance policy every adult who
comes into the country illegally is sent
to see a judge for possible prosecution
and that is when the parent is separated
from the child that separation can be
just a few hours or if the parent is
sent to jail it can be weeks months or
even years that was just a
administrative decision yes not a law
correct
we saw detainees eating snacks we're
told they get two hot meals a day they
can take showers every other day and
their clothes are laundered people
continue coming in and bigger numbers
bigger numbers
Manuel Padilla jr. the border patrols
Rio Grande sector chief says agents have
apprehended 108 thousand people so far
this year including more than 39,000
parents and their children and 14,500
minors who arrived at the border by
themselves what is separating families
help you do there is no policy to
separate family the zero tolerance
policy is intended to deter people from
breaking the law
adults Congressman Peter Welch
represents Vermont he toured the
facility yesterday what kind of Congress
from Vermont do to stop it well a
congressman from Vermont alone can't do
much but many congressmen in many
Americans speaking out can turn it
around this is an American it's
appalling and it's unnecessary at this
facility where we are detainees stay
here for no longer than 72 hours and
Border Patrol says what they try and do
is actually put the children separated
from their parents with other family
members already living in the US but
Gail sometimes that can take up to 57
days get this since the zero tolerance
policy went into effect in May more than
1,100 kids just at this facility have
been separated from their parents it is
a very complicated story in the bottom
line is the people despite all that
they've been through want to be in this
country they worked hard to get here and
they want to stay thank you David
thank you very much you always paint
such a picture